we are back again round two with the
executive chef of distill and remedy
chef jeff what are we making now round
two uh this is a fun riff on on pig
candy on pork belly pig candy yeah
exactly that's what i call it we called
pork belly uh for me it's pig candy okay
um but i'm gonna turn it into some tacos
because you know what's better than
watching the game something handheld you
can just totally eat at home you can
throw it right on your uh in your smoker
you can put it right into a saute pan a
little bit of oil let it cook at about
medium heat for about 20 minutes you're
going to finish it with i finished it
with a honey hot sauce you could finish
it with a barbecue or a similar sauce
would be like
a honey hot you can buy from the store
you can just get some fresh bell peppers
just slice them down nice and thin a
little bit of olive oil salt pepper
i like to put a little bit of garlic and
then just throw them in the oven and
just let them go i like to serve it with
a little bit of our cilantro lime slaw
it just cuts through that richness green
goddess you can buy which would be very
similar green goddess would be a great
uh
substitution for this then of course we
have to make it look pretty with all the
garnishes i just like to take a green
onion
throw it on the grill let it char up and
then finish it with some limes right
down the center
and there you go
and there you go you can find this
recipe and all the big game grub online
8newsnow.com and you've got to stay
tuned tomorrow it is the final showdown
soul belly barbecue and distilling
remedies they're going to share their
nacho recipes each have a little
different tweak to them you can see
which one is perfect for your big game
party who doesn't love nachos and all
the recipes are online right all of them